at the moero mine in eastern uganda
seventeen-year-old matthias is digging
for gold he says if he doesn't find any
he doesn't get paid
if you come back again
you try another chance
if you are not good again you go back
home
now sometimes you get little money like
or 20
10 000.
ten thousand ugandan shillings is the
equivalent of around two dollars and
eighty cents schools in uganda have been
closed since march 2020 shortly after
the first case of kovite 19 was
confirmed on the african continent
some classes reopened in february this
year but shut down again four months
later as the country faced a surge in
infections
when covered came in schools were closed
other activities got closed
it forced youths
to come in and evolve in this activity
to get what to get
some money for survival
it also forced younger children because
they had nothing to do
the un says uganda is now the only
country in africa where schools remain
closed sixteen-year-old annette worries
she'll never catch up on the school work
she's missed
staying at home sometimes
you cannot have a morale to read books
and
you can just somehow sometimes just to
forget what they they told they taught
at school
the government says they'll reopen
schools where more than 5 million of the
country's 44 million people are fully
vaccinated so far only 700 thousand have
been
this lockdown is expected to last until
early next year which means more
children in uganda will miss out on one
of the most important part of their
lives education victoria gatenbee al
jazeera